what do you think is rarest in the
universe you said we might be alone
what's hardest to build is another
engineering way to ask that
life
intelligence or consciousness so like
you said that we might be alone
which is the thing that's hardest to get
to
is it just the origin of life is it the
origin of intelligence is it the origin
of consciousness
so
um let me at first explain you my kind
of mental model what i think is needed
for life to appear
um
so
i imagine that at some point there was
this primordial
zoop of
amino acids and maybe some proteins in
the ocean and
you know some proteins were turning into
some other proteins through reaction
and you can almost think about this
uh cycle of what turns into what as
there is a graph essentially describing
which substance turns into some other
substance and essentially life means
that all the sudden in the graph has
been created a cycle such that the same
thing keeps on happening over and over
again that's what is needed for life to
happen and in some sense you can think
almost that you have this gigantic graph
and it needs like a sufficient number of
edges for the cycle to appear
um
then um from perspective of intelligence
and consciousness
my current intuition is that they might
be
quite intertwined first of all it might
not be that it's like a binary thing
that you have intelligence or
consciousness it seems to be a
more more
continuous component let's see if we
look for instance on the
even networks recognizing images and
people are able to show that the
activations of these networks correlate
very strongly with activations in visual
cortex
of some monkeys the same seems to be
true about language models
also if you for instance
look
if you train agent
in a 3d world
um at first you know it it it it barely
recognizes what is going on over the
time it kind of recognizes foreground
from a background over the time it kind
of knows where there is a foot
and it just follows it
over the time it actually starts having
a 3d perception so it is possible for
instance to look inside of the head of
an agent and ask what would it see if it
looks to the right and the crazy thing
is you know initially when the agents
are barely trained these predictions are
pretty bad over the time they they
become better and better you can still
see
that if you ask what happens when the
head is turned by 360 degrees for some
time they think that the different thing
appears and then at some stage they
understand actually that the same
thing's supposed to appear so they get
like a understanding of 3d structure
it's also you know very likely that they
have inside some
level of and of like a symbolic
reasoning like they're particularly
symbols for other agents so when you
look at dota agents they collaborate
together and uh and
you know they they they have some
anticipation of uh if if they would win
battle they have some some expectations
with respect to other agents i might be
you know too much anthropomorphizing
um the the how the things look
look for me but then the fact that they
have a symbol for other agents and makes
me believe that uh at some stage as the
uh you know as they are optimizing for
skills they would have also symbol to
describe themselves
this is like a very useful symbol to
have and this particularity i would call
it like a self-consciousness or
self-awareness
and still it might be different from the
consciousness so i guess the the way how
i'm
understanding the word consciousness
let's say the experience of drinking a
coffee or let's say experience of being
a butt
that's the meaning of the word
consciousness it doesn't mean to be
awake uh
yeah it feels
it might be also somewhat related to
memory and recurrent connections so
um it's kind of okay if you look at
anesthetic drugs they might be
they essentially
they disturb
brain waste
such that
[Music]
maybe memory is not not formed
so there's a lessening of consciousness
when you do that correct and so that's
one way to intuit what is consciousness
there's also kind of another
element here it could be that it's
you know this kind of self-awareness
module that you described
plus the actual subjective experience
is a storytelling module
that tells us a story about uh
what we're experiencing
the
crazy thing so let's say i mean in
meditation they teach people
not to speak story inside of the head
and there is also some fraction of
population
who doesn't have actually narrator i
know people who don't have a right
narrator and you know they have to use
external people in order to
kind of
solve tasks that require internal
narrator
so
it seems that it's possible to have that
experience without the talk
what are we talking about when we talk
about the internal narrator is that the
voice when you're like yeah i thought
that that's what you are referring to
well i was referring more on the like
not an actual voice
i meant like
there's some kind of
like subjective experience
feels like it's
it's fundamentally about storytelling to
ourselves
it feels like
like the feeling is a story
that is much
uh
much simpler abstraction than the raw
sensory information
so this feels like it's a very high
level abstraction
that uh
is useful
for me to feel like
entity in this world
most useful aspect of it is that
because i'm conscious
i think there's an intricate connection
to me not one
wanting to die
so like it's a useful hack to really
prioritize not dying
like those seem to be somehow connected
so i'm telling this story of like it's
richie feels like something to be me and
the fact that me exists in this world i
want to preserve me
and so that makes it a useful agent hack
so i will just refer maybe to the first
part as you said about the kind of story
of describing who you are
i was uh
thinking about that even so you know
obviously i'm i'm i like thinking about
consciousness uh i like thinking about
the ai as well and i'm trying to see
analogies of these things in ai what
would it correspond to so
um
you know openly i trained a
model called gpt
which
can generate a
i'm using text on arbitrary topic
and um
and one way to control gpd
is uh by putting into prefix at the
beginning of the text some information
what would be the story about
you can have even chat with uh
you know with gpt by saying that the
chat is with lex or elon musk or so and
gpt would just
pretend to be you or elon musk or so
and
it almost feels that this uh
story that we give ourselves to describe
our life it's almost like a things that
you put into context of gpt yeah
the context we provide to gpt
is uh
is multimodal it's so gpt itself is
multimodal gpt itself uh hasn't learned
actually from experience of single human
but from the experience of humanity it's
a chameleon you can turn it into
anything and in some sense by providing
context um
it you know
behaves as the thing that you wanted it
to be and it's interesting that the
you know people have a stories of who
they are
and as you said these stories they help
them to operate in the world um but it's
also you know interesting
i guess various people find it out
through meditation or so that
there might be some patterns that you
have learned
when you were a kid that actually are
not serving you anymore
and you also might be thinking that
that's who you are and that's actually
just a story
yeah so it's a useful hack but sometimes
it gets us into trouble it's a local
optima it's a local optimal
you